[Applause]
so what happens to your store when
nobody can shop anymore well it becomes
a pain in the ass when the whole store
is under glass a newly opened Walgreens
in downtown Chicago reportedly has only
two aisles of merchandise that isn't
locked behind anti-theft devices which
is nuts opening a new store in Chicago
in 2021 Walgreens Executives lamented
the impact of shoplifting on their
bottom line shutting multiple locations
and investing heavily in security
measures but then they recanted saying
the theft problem was overstated CFO
James Kehoe even told investors hey
maybe we cried too much about the whole
shoplifting thing well you could have
fooled the customers in Chicago the new
stores designed more like a prison than
a retail shop although Walgreens claims
this is an improvement by letting
employees shop for you
which means any item deemed
non-essential by management must be
ordered at a kiosk unlocked by a clerk
and picked up at the counter the two
aisles of products actually opened to
the public included a limited selection
of snacks and basic toiletries and get
this the shelves have been lowered so
would-be criminals can't hide well
unless the store gets attacked by evil
elves
all right
look at my shirt all right hotep dude
this idea of the clerks doing the
shopping for you no offense to the
clerks at Walgreens
but you know it sounds like a bad idea
I'm probably going to get my packages
faster from Amazon than I will from from
some minimum wage employee yeah what
does even Walgreens mean I was thinking
about it like Walgreens they need to
Rebrand if they're gonna lock everything
up in the back they should just Rebrand
as a cannabis dispensary yes
greens yeah
as long as they leave out the bubble gum
and the condoms then it's going to be a
great night I'm definitely stealing
those
I'm actually locked up but not that I
would know but that they're because it
does it's what they're basically saying
is all things over like a certain price
yeah are are all locked up and and you
can steal the gum take the gum and the
Tic Tacs cats
do you have you been to a store ever
foreign
yeah but it's been a while yes well Otep
is right though it's like when you keep
introducing these obstacles it's just
you're just gonna make Amazon the only
place left absolutely oh I have given so
much money to Jeff Bezos it's not even
funny yeah because I mean I was trying
to think about the Walgreens by my
apartment I don't know how many aisles
are open because I haven't been there in
so long right it might be similar
because it's like you go there to get
five things that's five times you got to
press a little button and be like sorry
like you really need like each employee
to be your own personal shopper as you
go through the store because everything
needs to be I mean because you feel bad
after a while you're like I guess I
don't need toothpaste yes because you
have to ring the button and then you
have to go something so you ring the
button again it's like you should just
be assigning your own personal person as
you go through the store because it's
nobody wants to go through this it takes
forever yeah especially and I think that
this is coming about because there were
no other clerks available to even ring
up stuff because every everybody's out
like going to get somebody else's
mouthwash yeah you know um Tyrus I'm
really curious about I finally figured
out that I may actually feel like you
now walking through CVS does the lower
the shelves they lower the shelves
because like they're saying it's like
basically the shelves are like prison
bathrooms right they you know they they
uh wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait wait hold him hold the horse
there he was cool for a minute now he's
around saying I'm been in prison no I
was saying that if you ever see in
prisons no I haven't those stalls only
come up in a year so you they can see
that there's no hanky-panky going on
it's very unnatural it's often like the
bathrooms and private jets or this
conversation
it's nothing better than your
convenience store being turned into the
DMV yeah because you have to take a
number and it's always going to be like
182 b and sit in chairs and wait for a
clerk who's mad to come up with you and
walk with you while you pick out things
that you don't want people to know you
have to buy like you have to get the
morning after pill or you got to get
your ointments
[Music]
you know what I'm saying four pill yeah
it's actually just a magazine you know
and all that fun stuff that you don't
want you try to you used to be able to
camouflage when she sent you the store
for tampons yeah you camouflage it with
a bunch of other stuff now the person's
like is it super absorbent hold on I
gotta text her hold on you know and then
fights are gonna happen because
someone's gonna be mad that they're not
getting their turn you just had some I
mean this is a horrible like all this is
is just a good excuse for the
corporation to go we're done yep we're
done we've tried everything we can so
now you can order online to a Walgreens
and have it shipped to you yeah so the
the the group that it really hurts on a
serious note the elderly and the people
who pretend who need their prescriptions
drugs and stuff they're not going to get
them anymore and it's just what you're
talking about people who just live in
these neighborhoods not the people that
steal for from them no yeah the people
that live there and then what happens
Molly is you get these stories like
about food deserts right like oh my God
you know nobody it's like well the
reason why there's a desert there is
because every time you move there it
gets taken yeah no exactly I don't want
to sound hyperbolic but I think this
story is about the complete end of
civilization might be that is not
hyperbolic at all like remember you're
on Fox News That's level three yeah we
can actually we can actually move it up
but we have all these things that like
all conspire together to create really
bad situations the breakdown of Law and
Order tolerance for tolerance for theft
like a lot of these employees are told
they shouldn't do anything if there's
theft in their store and we as a society
have just embraced all of this and it is
important to go to your neighborhood
store like it's not just about getting
Goods it's about having human
conversations with other people and you
can't do that on Amazon and I wish
people would work to like restore their
neighborhood stores it is because it
always goes I don't know who said this
but you can always tell when Society is
in decline by watching what insurance
companies do so insurance companies are
telling uh clerks to just take it don't
stop so sooner or later that's not going
to work and they're not going to ensure
these businesses they're no longer
insuring homes State Farm is no longer
ensuring homes in California because of
the fires because they never solved the
fire the fire problem so now they're
just not going to insure your home
that's the end then you got to move to
Texas where they do have insurance
crazy and good governance yeah I told
you I can out hyperbole you it's not
just a civilization Molly the whole
world the whole world the universe is
totally screwed
this is Satan's America you know what
we're too bad for Satan Satan doesn't
want us yeah
carried away in
no Sodom and Gomorrah in real time no I
don't I'm gonna sit this one out all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else